c'est un statu quo insoutenable pour les
habitants de marioupol assiégée et
bombardée sans relâche par les russes
depuis une semaine
ces cinq cent mille habitants attendent
toujours leur évacuation sans cesse
promise sans cesse retardé hier ses
dizaines de bus ont attendu toute la
journée que la route soit sécurisé en
vain
nous n'avons aucune confirmation qu'un
cessez-le-feu soit planifiée pour
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas facile d'avoir
des informations parce que depuis six
jours la ville n'a plus d'électricité
d'eau de systèmes sanitaires ou encore
de téléphone
la russie propose ce matin cessez le feu
et l'ouverture de couloirs humanitaires
pour quatre villes mario paul soul nie
kiev et kharkiv mais à une condition que
ses habitants prennent la direction de
la russie et de la biélorussie
ces corridors humanitaires se
dérouleront sous le contrôle de l'armée
russe elle effectuera une surveillance
de ces évacuations par des drones
une demande de la france affirme moscou
l'elysée dément fermement
le cren elle juge la proposition
inacceptable
en attendant la russie poursuit sa
guerre comme dans cette ville de cramât
torse que dans l'est de l'ukraine ou des
frappes de missiles ont touché ce matin
des immeubles et une école de personnes
ont été tuées le président céline ski
qui craint une offensive d'envergure
la russie a officiellement annoncé qu'il
y aura des bombardements sur notre
territoire ils viseront nos usines notre
complexe de défense des milliers de
personnes y travaillent il s'agit de
meurtres
aujourd'hui impossible d'avoir un bilan
des victimes
seule certitude plus d'un million et
demi d'ukrainiens sont sur les routes de
l'exil